[Music]
you
hello friends to be back to the continue
from the last class where we studied
what is cognitive psychology and what is
the subject matter of cognitive
psychology so in that class earlier
class we saw the basic subject matter of
cognitive psychology what are the
various inputs from various schools of
psychology to cognitive psychology what
is it that we study in cognitive
psychology and the various paradigms
which are there for the study of
cognitive psychology how they explain
mental events and metal facts in the
last class we discuss cognition is about
understanding mental events and metal
facts or how does mental processing take
place on mental events and how does the
mind come into play and what role the
blame has in the mind in today's lecture
we'll look at the various ways of
studying cognition what are the various
methods which are available for studying
cognition so let's begin there from the
start of cognitive psychology and the or
the heydays of cognitive psychology
there were several methods which was out
there to studying cognitive psychology
the basic method that primitive
cognitive psychology or artificial
intelligence used didn't employ any rule
of brain into it so the earlier the
first advent of cognitive psychology or
the first wave of cognitive psychology
basically banked on information
processing theory and so information
processing theory was all about mental
processing how mental events get process
to save several mental mechanisms and
what is the input what is the output
that kind of
process or that kind of structure was
what you're being studied by cognitive
psychology so information for century as
we saw in the last class actually looks
at the events and the mechanisms rusting
and isms through which mental events or
mental activity is generated in contrast
artificial intelligence was also looking
at how at the process level mental
events are studied and both of these
methods did not play or did not
emphasize the brain in any ways as we
know today that the mind is actually a
software kind of a software or mind is
actually a fact which is made by the
brain and so studying of the brain is
very important in studying according to
psychology now some of the main reasons
why the brain should be included in the
study of cognitive psychology is to
understand the dissociation and
Association the process of dissociation
and associations because these
dissociations and associations will tell
us what processes are similar if two
mental acts takes place and what
processes are different if in two mental
events or two mental process acts to the
heart of this debate is the idea of
localizing those brain areas defining
are those brain areas which actor which
you activity when a particular cognitive
at a particular cognitive process is
initiated and so what the new diet
cognitive psychology or the new field of
cognitive psychology is looking at not
only the information processing or the
artificial intelligence approach where
mental crosses events and various other
mental events are studied but in
relation to it
the new wave of quality psychology is
also looking at brain areas of how brain
areas are what brain areas are really
involved in producing cognition there
are multiple methods of studying
cognitive psychology as I said and so
each of these methods use a different
measure a different way to study
cognition now these methods all have
their own problems and all have their
own limitations and war has to have what
to study to you to find out the complete
method or perfect method to study
cognition would take into account the
improves from all these methods why
should we do that we should do that as
multiple methods when they provide
information what would happen is that
the limitation of one method could
become the benefit of other method and
the benefit of our method could serve as
or could add up to more important
information and so when looking at
multiple methods when looking at
multiple ways multiple ideas or multiple
approaches to studying cognition this
will give us a more complete picture or
a more desirable outcome of what
cognition is all about now the general
goal of cognitive psychology is to study
dissociations and associations at the
level of the brain
now when I say dissociation Association
what is it that I actually mean
dissociation is a fact or a term which
explains that one if two processes or if
two mantilax give rise to activation in
one area of the brain how do we
dissociate it simply stating what it
would really mean that an event if an
event or a variable leads to brain
activation during the processing of one
task but
we do the brain activation on the other
tasks this is what dissociation is this
will tell us which task requires that
particular mental activity or that
particular mental process and which of
the tasks doesn't require that
particular mental task let's understand
this with an example Allen Bradley
developed the idea of working memory and
so what Bradley said is that there is a
whole conceptualization of the central
executive component of memory which
executes most of the working process in
in working memory and within the central
executive or with the central executive
or other parts of the working memory
which is the spatial store and the
phonological loop the idea of the
working memory is conceptualized in this
way that input or the encoding from the
environment is thrown into the central
executive which then assigns the audio
input the auditory input into the
phonological loop and the visual input
into the spatial and spatial loop or the
spatial store what does this mean it
means that at the level of processing
itself at the level of encoding itself
or just after encoding the mind takes
away two inputs from two different
senses and processes them separately now
the same region of the brain is involved
in storing the phonological loop or the
phonological matter and the special
matter is that true
so experiments are done to find out
whether this and there as the assigning
of the visual input and the auditory
input in two different stores or the
working memory whether they use
the same mental mental process or the
same brain areas and if different brain
areas were activated then we could say
then would the tasks the tasks of
assigning the the auditory input into
the phonological loop and the visual
input into the spatial sketchpad they
require different main areas and through
this we can then specifically study one
of these area of the deficits in one of
these areas so Alan Bradley what he did
was he did some studies to find out what
really happens at the level of the brain
so we specifically inhabited or the
visual input and he saw that there was
no deficit into the auditory input what
he did was he gave a visual task to his
subject and with this visual task he
actually loaded the working memory or
the attention the attention span with
more data more items and when that
happened the subject was not able the
subject could not process the visual
input but the auditory input was intact
let's understand this in a more easy
example
so what Alan Bradley wanted to study is
whether if the visual input is loaded
whether the auditory input can function
on its own meaning which both the
processes are both the processes of
visual input and the auditory input in
the working memory I have dissociative
processes or dissociative brain regions
involved into it
so in his task he gave visual tasks and
loaded the attention or loaded the
central executive with more visual
information so that selects are not able
to rehearse are not able to study back
the visual inputs but
the auditory input the auditory
information which was taught in
phonological loop got a proper rehearsal
and so when a test was done it was found
out that although the subjects not able
to correctly identify visual items or
visual matter auditory inputs or
auditory tests or auditory information
retrieval was not at all this stuff
this particular experiment shows that
dissociation is at the core of study
cognition why because dissociation can
tell about tell us which processes have
similar although they have similar
representations but they use different
mechanisms similar to it is the study of
associations in associations what we
actually study is whether two different
processes are linked or two different
processes actually excite the same brain
region for example in this case
experiments were done to find out
whether the frontal cortex the frontal
regions and another area of brain
whether both of them have anything to do
with spatial representations or of
encoding or special in entered Earth
spatial encodings what they found out is
that special in information when encoded
through two different processes or two
different brain regions gave rise to
similar presentations meaning which both
the brain processes or Road the brain
areas although different but they
combined lis give right give rise to
same interpretations now why is the
study of dissociation Association
important the study of dissociation and
Association is important to find out
which processes all those are emanate
from the same structure but they lead to
different tasks and which if two
different processes which emanate from
different brain areas converge on to
particular task to find out the
specificity to find out the process to
this know the methods of studying
cognition so there are four different
methods through which cognition can be
studied and so these methods are the
behavioral methods the correlation
neural method the causal method and the
modeling within the modeling we have the
box model approach and the neural
network model approach so let's start
with the behavioral methods what the
wavering methods generally do is they
look at directly observable behavior
like reaction time the time one person
takes to react to something or accuracy
of how accurate retrieval is from
encoding so these processes or these
events responses are mapped on to
behavioral methods the accuracy of
response or the time taken to response
gives us an idea on to what behavioral
processes are going through in the
processing of a particular mental event
now researchers they attempt to draw
inferences about what kind of
interpretations and what kind of
processing leads to the differences in
accuracy and differences in reaction
time for popular approaches there have
been or for popular methods within the
behavioral method has been used so what
we look at is what is the banner what
are the benefits of teach methods what
are the drawbacks and that kind of thing
into less so let's go into that
comparison as you can see the major
behavioral methods and methods used in
cognitive psychology the major methods
are looking at the accuracy of how
accurate the retrieval is from the
encoding percentages that is percentage
of correct responses response times
judgments and protocol now let's take
this methods one by one the method of a
in this method of accuracy a very good
example to look at is item recall or
memory recall for item such as
remembering a particular job
requirements of our particular task the
advantage is this it gives an objective
idea of the processing effectiveness how
effective is the mental mechanism or the
mental process which is processing that
particular even the limit to accuracy
method or behavioral methods of accuracy
is something called the ceiling effect
and floor effect ceiling effect is when
a task is made too easy so that each
person gets the highest score and so it
will be very difficult to find out the
exact works across a mechanism similarly
this is the floor effect in which a task
is made so difficult that none of the
people are able to solve it and due to
this will not be able to ascertain what
processing mechanisms are at play
also they suffer from something called
speed accuracy trade-off which means
that as we want to be more accurate on
something the more time it will it is
going to take as accuracy increases more
accurate we want the speed decreases or
the time to perform a task decreases
it's an inverse relationship
the second method here is response time
which is the time one takes to come up
with a particular response the advantage
is this that it is an objective method
and suitable for measuring or processing
mechanisms that is at play and also
those unconscious processing mechanisms
now this the limitation to this method
is something called experimental
expectancy effect and task demands what
this really means is that each
experimenter when he gets into an
experiment he has certain expectancy he
has a certain want from the subjects and
so this is the transfer of the subject
subject
identifies this expectancy and actually
behaves in a similar way so if
x-parameter ones are subject to say yes
to most of the things or take more time
in responding what would really happen
in the subject understands that or
judges that from the from the
experimenter and even if the processing
is fast they take more time the third
method is called the judgment method
here what really happens is to find out
what really what really is happening in
our how does about any process really
work is people are given a judgment
scale and so there are several these are
seven point or eight point nine point
scales which are given to people who
actually judge or go ahead and rate how
they are processing a particular item it
is very inexpensive to collect and it
access the subjects reaction to a
particular cognitive process for example
the thing like how are you feeling right
now
and so our tests can be given to people
and what they could do is actually go
ahead and on a seven-point scale go
ahead and tell on several questions of
provide responses to several questions
as to how they are feeling the problem
with this method is that subjects are
not aware of how to use this scale and
so may get into difficulty the last two
the behavioral methods which are used to
study cognition is something called the
protocol collection the method here
allows subject to verbally announce what
is going on or what they are doing for
example if I ask someone to go ahead and
show me how counting of two and three is
done this person has to actually start
the first the experiment the subject has
to actually go ahead and relate how he
is how is doing the addition process for
example thinking of the number two
thinking of the rule for addition
thinking of the number three going
adding carrying off and so on the
protocol method really uses or really
requires the subject to announce what is
going on mentally this method can tell
you or the advantage of this method is
basically it
what are the steps basic strips through
which a mental processing happens or any
task what is the mental requirement for
this task what is the mental process for
this task for complex cognitive
processes this cannot obviously be used
because people would not be aware of
what is going on and they could not or
they could not accurately go ahead and
describe what is being going on the next
method that we use in studying cognition
or cognitive processes is a correlation
or the neural methods no what does
correlation really mean or what is this
what is the heart of this matter the
heart of this method is localization as
we discussed in the start of a lecture
that the new wave of cognitive science
is looking up at the brain towards the
brain to explain how these cognitive
processes or mental events are being
processed or how is the mental event
actually being processed what is going
on inside the mind what is going on
inside the subjects cognition how is the
processing input and output coming into
effect No
then I explained to you that the brain
is a recent addition why because the
brain can objectively tell you the
processing the methods or by through
which particular mental event is being
processed and so this method looks at
finding out or localizing that area of
the brain when a particular mental event
is being carried out what this method
does is actually tries to form a
correlation between the fact that when a
mental event happens which areas of the
brain actually show activity and so
through correlation it tries to show off
or tries to find out which area of the
brain risk is responsible for which kind
of mental activity this will benefit us
as we will be able to specifically now
tell that each mental process or each
event or each mental mechanism is
related to a particular brain area the
problem here could be that sometimes
numerous other brain areas beside the
area of interest also get excited and so
it is it is a little bit difficult or I
would say a little challenging to
pinpoint the area that is responsible
for the core mental process which is
being carried out another problem with
this method is correlation doesn't lead
to causation correlation simply means
the two events by chance are related to
each other they don't mean that process
a leads to process B and so we cannot
with confidence say that this brain area
excitation of a particular brain area
leads to a particular mental even a
particular mental process a particular
cognitive illness now there are a couple
of techniques which I hear so let's look
at those techniques let's look at the
advantages of these techniques and the
disadvantages of this technique and
discuss how this method really works so
the causal neural methods have four
different techniques to look at I'm
sorry three different techniques to look
at and these techniques are the neuro
physiological studies the transcranial
magnetic stimulation and the drugs so I
was saying as I was saying the
correlational neural method the problems
with the correlation of neural method
and so there are two problems with this
first that many areas side along or they
get along or are activated in addition
to the meaning of interest and so what
really happens the problem with this
method is to localize the area of
interest because there are other areas
also which inside along gets activated
and the second problem with the
correlational method is that correlation
not causing causation now what really
happens in correlation is two events a
and B they also show in sync activity
but correlation doesn't guarantee that a
is the cause of me or B is caused by a
and so there is no way to find out what
process leads to or what method leads to
what structural activation in terms of
the brain mind relations it would be
very difficult to find out whether the
activation in area lead to the mental
processing or whether mental processing
leads to the activation in an area so
there are four different methods here
techniques here to study the correlation
or the correlational localization of
rain areas the first of this technique
is the EEG or the electroencephalogram
the electroencephalograph can also be
used for recording something called the
ER piece now what the EEG or the
electroencephalograph records are
potentials from the scalp when a
particular mental activity takes place
it's believed that a mental when a
there are changes in neuronal polarity
and due to this a weak electrical
current actually passes to the scalp
surface the EEG sensors which are placed
in the scalp at record these activities
and based on that are able to predict
whether there is an activity change from
the baseline activity a baseline
activity is an activity when no mental
processing is being taking place and and
then whenever an activity change place
there will be a change and so the change
the activity subtracted from the
baseline activity will give you the kind
of mental activity which is being taken
place
Iggy's are also used for recording event
related potentials which are basically
the potentials which are recorded when a
particular stimulus is set and so after
a particular stimulus is initiated from
there on to when the response or the
system or when the response of a person
takes place the EEG
the
the electrons are left in
encephalographic patterns of the brain
are recorded and the time course of this
EEG the time the changes in EEG from the
stimulus onset to the response is
calculated or recorded or studied and
this gives us an idea of what processes
and what areas or what kind of pattern
of activity is being shown by the brain
generally there are some very fixed
patterns that the brain show there is
something called the base activity that
mostly happens in everyday life is the
Alpha activity which falls in the 8 to
13 Hertz or 13 cycle per second
region then if as a person gets more
relaxed either at the amplitude of these
waves increases and the frequency lowers
down and it comes back to something
called Delta and so on and so forth so
as you get more worked up as you are
doing more general activity the
amplitude is less the frequency is more
and the band pattern or the activity
pattern in the brain is generally in the
8 to 14 Hertz cycle / or cycle per
second region an example of using the
EEG is to find out brain patterns during
sleep or something like in terms of ERP
something like p300 now p300 is actually
a component which happens p300 is when I
say a component what does it really mean
a component is a deviation in an
electrical activity which takes place
after the start of a event so when a
stimulus is given when a stimulus is
initiated and the ages are recorded 300
milliseconds after the simulation
stimulus initiated on the positive
direction if a peak is recorded this is
called the p300 now the p300 generally
the component p300 generally is
associated with novelty so when the
brain then the process the mind looks at
something which is normal which is new
it generates the p300 activity and so
these this this can be recorded the
spatial resolution of eg is very poor
because it cannot locate the area from
where or the neuronal group from where
this activity is being recorded as
current passes or current moves from the
base of the brain towards the surface of
the brain it forms a chronicle structure
and so it loses most of its strength and
it is very difficult to to go back in or
to reverse-engineer from where the
source of this activity is although
newer techniques do allow for something
called source localization which
actually from an EEG will point point a
gross area where it is coming from but
generally speaking the EEG is a very
poor resolution in terms of temporal
resolution and EEG is excellent because
it can show you within within
milliseconds of the activity when within
milliseconds of the mental event the
mental activity and can show a
correlation to that so in terms of time
of processing in terms of time course of
processing of mental events the EEG is
very good can tell you what events in in
that on the time axis what events
process process or what even processes
take place that that kind of information
can be there gathered from an EEG the
invasiveness of this particular method
of the EEG is very low as you don't have
to put anything inside the body the
surface sensors actually captures the
information and so not much of an
invasive process and the cost for this
particular method is very low if smaller
units are available in in very few
dollars so you can buy them and start
using them similar to the EEG is the M
eg the magnet to Instagram where
electrical activity instead of capturing
the electrical activity the magnet of
activity is captured an example is
detecting activity from the auditory
cortex or different picture stones so
here there are several sensors which are
put around
the brain and the magnetic activity that
is generated when a particular event
happens a particular stimulus on after
the particular state was stimulus the
particular event which happens are
recorded or the magnetic activity or
which is generated by the neuronal group
which is present the event are captured
through it the spatial resolution of the
magnet or in circular graph is very good
it is under one centimetre in terms of
temporal resolution also it is very good
is excellent the invasiveness since you
are not putting anything inside the body
it is very low and so invasiveness wise
Remy G's are very good but the problem
is buying an M eg or establishing a and
M eg requires a very high cost so cost
wise it requires a system which produces
this magnetic moments of this predator
produces magnetic fields which actually
are able to process or which actually
are able to record changes in brain
activity or neuronal activity and a
particular mental event is going on
third method that we use as a
correlational method or for localizing
brain areas that are responsible for a
particular mental event is the positron
emotion tomography the PE T in cognitive
psychology which we generally use the 15
oh I saw tok the 15 oxygen isotope as a
method for doing PE T so what really
happens is that the oxygen the 15 the Oh
15 isotope which is radioactive is
injected with normal within the normal
body and so this particular isotope is
moving around the body so when the brain
does it is believed that the when when
the brain does a particular function it
pulls up more and more blood and with
the blood more and more water also
transposed to the brain and so when a
particular region of the brain shows
more 15 the accumulation of more 15 I
sort of that is the region which is
correlated or which is assumed to be
active in a particular process and this
is how the pet of 15 or oxygen isotope
is done generally it is used to study or
mostly it is used to study language
in the brain of how the language areas
process or what is the processing that
happens in language area when we
actually speak the spatial resolution is
very good up to one centimeter but the
temporal resolution is very poor because
it takes almost 40 seconds to generate
an image out of the PT of 15 oxygen
isotope or the Oh 15 isotope
invasiveness is high as we in as we
inject an isotope of oxygen which is
radioactive into the blood and so this
has radioactive properties which could
lead to problems although the kind of
radioactivity that happens with an
oxygen with Oh 15 I so talk is as less
as what a airline pilot would actually
get through in half a year of his work
so it is it is very very less but still
it is radioactive and so it's best to
avoid it on terms of the purchased cost
it's a high purchase cost because PE t
means cyclotron and PD cameras and
things for noticing those sensors which
can go ahead and record the
radioactivity the low radioactivity of
these oxygen isotope so it's very costly
in that method and improvement on the PT
is the MRI and the fMRI which was which
is a new addition to the study of the
brain or brain processes or cognitive
processes the MRI on on one hand is
actually stool's
the structural integrity of how the
structure of the brain is the fMRI on
the other hand shows the blocks blood
oxygen level dependent or how much
oxygenated blood is taken up by the
brain when a particular activity is
being being processed by the brain the
MRI works on the principle of body
magnets or at atoms of the of the body
and how they align to an external
magnetic field so what the American
really does it
a uniform magnetic field to which most
atoms of the body align and then a radio
ad pulse is created or radio pulse is it
is generated which disturbs the
alignment of most atoms or the of the
area which is in the MRI scanner the
speed of returning back is calculated
when when the magnets dis align when the
particular polls or the particular
elements in the in the body the
particular atoms of elements in the body
when a radioisotope dis aligns them from
the alien from the alignment that the
MRI magnet does it returns back and the
speed with which the return back is
calculated and from there an image is
generated and these images are the speed
at which the different atoms get back or
they come back is different for
different different media like bone skin
or that other tissues in the body they
have different speeds of returning back
or this is calculated and an image is
generated in an fMRI what we really do
is the amount of oxygenated blood in
comparison to the deoxygenated blood at
a particular brain region which is
processing a particular event is taking
that is calculated and that gives us an
idea of which region of the brain is
showing an activity through a sensor the
spatial resolution F and both an MRI and
fMRI is very superb it's very good in
the terms of millimeter range the
temporal resolution is not that good but
it depends upon the level of resolution
that you want or generally it is in in
terms of several seconds so not like the
EEG which can give you the millisecond
kind of a temporal resolution but not as
low as the PE T which gives which takes
almost 40 seconds to produce an image so
MRIs have this indecent time requirement
or this takes decent time
produces images the invasiveness is low
because MRI doesn't MRI and fMRI doesn't
inject anything into the body so the
invasive is low but here the purchase
cost is very high because the kind of
magnets that that the MRI and fMRI uses
are huge electromagnets and they have
huge amount of cost involved into them
the last method that we use here is
called the optical imaging method and
here this is a recent addition so it has
been found out that the brain is
transparent to certain kind of light
waves and when these lights waves are
shown into the brain through a laser the
speed with which they return back can
give you an idea of how much blood is
flowing to that particular area and so
this can be used this method is now
being used to find out the amount of
blood traveling through a particular
area depending on how much light laser
light is being reflected back through
various tissues and and various
substances in the brain it's the special
resolution at present is very poor and
the temporal resolution it depends on
the level of resolution and several
minutes takes up for from forming an
image the invasiveness is generally
medium to low as lasers are shown on -
although the lasers are focused on to
your brain so it has some level of and
invasiveness but not too high the cost
of patching is very low but the temporal
and spatial resolution is not
appropriate one of the examples is they
can awright which is functional optical
imaging suit which is available these
days
another method of studying cognition is
through using the car general method of
training cognition what does this method
do in this method it is assumed that if
certain regions of the brain are
required for certain activity what would
happen if that region of the brain is
somehow not allowed to do any activity
or stop from doing activity and so one
of the one of the particular
Methos within this approach is using
patients who have certain brain damage
so suppose the Broca's area is
responsible for speech and so if
somebody has a deficit in the blocker
area and if certain type of speech
related experiments are given to to them
and compared to a particular person it
would be easy to understand what kind of
what kind of activity into the brain
does what is the requirement of this
area and so on and so forth so here in
this in in the near physiological
studies patients with localized brain
damage or brain damage to certain areas
are use and they compared with people
who have no brain damage and this is how
the cognitive processes or the mental
processes that go on when a particular
mental activity is being done is
actually studied example could be
deficit in understanding then how nouns
and verbs are processed and so people
who have deficit in this area if you
give them a noun in a verb the area
since this deficit will note it will
show no activity whereas people who
don't have deficits will show different
activity and so that will be enough to
say that this area is responsible for
the particular kind of act that is being
required the advantages is of this
method is testing theories of causal
role of specific brain areas testing
theories of shared indistinct crossing
and use in different tasks relative ly
easy and inexpensive to collect the
limitation is we do not find too many
people who have damaged areas and so the
idea is it's it's very difficult to find
people with damaged areas also when
damage to a particular area is there
there will be related areas which might
be affected by the damage so it is very
difficult to localize whether this
damage is to this area or with this
damage the damage
area also has any relation with other
areas the second method in this
particular group is called the
transcranial magnetic stimulation now in
TMS there are two types of TMS s one is
called the single pulse and the other is
called the repeated TMS or the repeated
transfer pulse may transmit transcranial
magnetic stimulation what clearly
happens here is that a huge coil is put
into or near or on the surface of an
area that you want to temporarily
inhibit and a large current is passed
through this coil the magnetic field
that is generated by this coil
temporarily inhabits a particular area
and through through that we can find out
whether the disturb how what will happen
if a particular area which is known to
be associated with a particular activity
cognitive activity if it is disrupted
what really happens so what we could do
or a studies of how visual imagery is
different from perception can be done by
using PMS a PMS are using a our TMS and
blocking the occipital lobe now there is
a difference between single person - MS
and our TMS in single person TMS a
single pulse is given after the stimulus
is is generated and the time course of
this pulse is recorded and that gives us
an idea of how the or what activity is
happening in that area whereas in our
TMS repeated pulses are given over a
particular area so that these weak
pulses they add up together to inhabit a
particular area the inhibition happens
because the neurons under that area
becomes too fast
to to extended or the the fired so many
times that they they go through a phase
of non firing and that inhabits the area
or that depolarization in
that activity in that area so advantages
it has the same advantage as the
neurophysiological studies but here and
the lesions are restricted and also the
idea here is that in these regions in in
in the TMS the the destruction is for a
very blue brief period of time and so
patients can come out out of it or
subjects can come out of it also TMS is
can be done from their surface areas it
cannot be done for deep areas of the
brain and so it is one of the
disadvantage or limitation of this
particular method another method which
can relate or which can show where how a
particular brain area destructing about
the particular brain area has effects on
a particular mental process is using
specific drugs so you have what happens
is first for a particular drug is
specifically used and these drugs
inhabit a particular area of interest
and so once this area of interest is
inhabited the same task is given to a
person who has taken this drug which
inhabits area and a person who has not
had drugs which inhabits this area and
comparisons are made these comparisons
give us an idea of what really happens
or how mental processes what brain areas
are involved what mental processes has
been processed and what is the time
course of process of these mental events
the problem example whose the disruption
of destructive action of not adrenaline
which is crucial for the operation of
hippocampus over not literally an
injection is given to the hippocampus
and the hippocampus actually becomes
temporarily disturbed and so when you
give a memory task to this person he
will not be able to process this memory
task and not come up with better of how
or this particularly travel paradigm in
comparison to somebody who has no
disruptions and this will show how much
or to what extent does which part of
hippocampus relates to a particular
memory type drugs been used to inhabit a
particular area affects not only the
area of interest but also affects other
area which is related to this area and
so this if
can also be a can can can be generalized
to other areas similar similar to this
effect the TMS also has this particular
disadvantage where activation of a
particular area can lead to activation
or subsequent areas and so what would
happen is the disruption will not be in
that particular area but also move out
or generalize to other areas of brain
and so to stay with confidence that this
is this destruction of this area is
responsible particular motive lag is
becomes a little bit dicey also the
limitation is that many drugs can create
many other problem and so this is this
has to be used under supervision the
last method that we discuss here are
studying cognition recovery psychology
is using modeling so in psychology
models are implemented as computer
programs which are meant to mimic the
underlying mental representation and
processes that produces different
specific types of human performances
so generally models are made and this
models try and explain the different
processes events that actually happen
when a particular mental event or a
particular cognition happens there are
two types of models which are studied in
cognitive psychology one of these is the
process model and the second is the
neural network model so what is the
process model the process model
specifies a sequence of processes that
converts an input into output and can
these kind of processes can be used to
generate flowcharts so basically it's
it's a box diagram kind of a thing where
you get from one for one phase to
another fun event to another event and
the processes which relate these events
together coming back to understanding
the process model let's recall the
structure process trade-off that we saw
in the last class and so in the last
class we saw Sternberg's example in
which what he did was he
he wanted to study the mental process of
how comparisons are made in in the
comparisons and made in cognition and so
what he did was he gave he subjects a
particular number of items to remember
and then these items were tested the
retrieval of these the memory for these
items were tested to a pro and what
Strandberg proposed is that this search
for the target in the list of item that
is being studied other that is being
remembered happens to a serial process
generally speaking this idea that a
civil process looked through a list of
items which have been strained in memory
can be explained through a process model
and this is the process model which
explains how this serial processing
takes place so generally how this
experiment would work is when a probe is
given the probe is first encoded prior
to this people are given a list to
remember and the list has several
numbers or several letters into it and
what the job is the subjects look at a
probe and then find out whether this
probe is present in this list or not and
to explain this process a process model
can be developed how will the process
model really works look at this in
finding out or scanning whether the
probe is present in the list which is
remembered the first step is encoding of
the probe this is followed by scanning
and comparing their processes internal
processes take the probe and match it
with each item which is represented
which is stored into the memory for each
item after a comparison a decision has
to be made so let's say this if we have
one two three four and five stored list
of items stored or five numbers stored
in our memory and if you want to compare
whether three is present or not how this
model we
really work on how this process will
really work in terms of mental effect is
that three is first encoded later on
three is matched scanned and compared
with the first item this which is one
and so a decision has to be made here
whether one is three or not since both
the representations for three and one
are different responses to be executed
here the responses know and the process
moves to the second item now three is
taken in compared with two since both
the representations are different
response here has to be generated which
says the three is not equal to two and
so we don't find a match and we move to
the third item which is three now here
three and three I have the same
representations and so we get a yes
response make a decision the yes
response comes in and so in terms of
serial processing the process doesn't
stop here it continues continues to the
end of the list and then gives the final
answer so that is how the process model
explains the process model X actually
goes ahead and explains how this simple
job or simple task of comparing a probe
with list which has been already
remembered actually goes ahead the
problem with this process model is it
tells you about the processes that goes
through or the processes that happen
when this list comparison or probe list
testing is done but it doesn't tell you
how does the brain or what neural
factors play a role in to this
particular whole structure so this has
this is basically this kind of process
models are basically influenced by the
behaviors which believe that the input
output sequence is what is of important
to us but what is inside is not of
importance to us and so it doesn't give
you the brain structures the brain
processes which actually go ahead and
lead to the final final answer of
comparisons or final comparisons that
are done and so to counter that neural
network models were done or thought of
now what is the neural retina Network
model it relies on interconnected units
which are not just input/output units
but it has a hidden hidden unit which is
generally called the brain unit into it
and so most inputs are connected to a
hidden unit and the hidden unit are
further connected to an output unit so
if an encoding if a input unit is given
this input unit then goes ahead and
makes connections with this hidden units
which are generally neurons now this
type of the neural network structure
that I'm showing you is a simple
feed-forward Network what happens here
is there are three units l1 l2 and three
three inputs which have been taken and
these inputs are then compared or their
process through h1 h2 h3 three different
brain networks or neuronal networks now
each of this network can have only two
activity one is either it can be
excitatory which is the eye response or
inhibitory or response so when a
particular input a particular
representation from the environment is
encoded this particular network of this
particular responder on network will
either be excitatory will either pass
along with either move along this
information to the next record and so
for connection or it could show
inhibitory whereas it will not process
this information further also these
connections that the input layer or the
input item has with the hidden layer has
weights into it and depending on what
weight it is what is the strength of
this connection will decide whether this
in half wins whether this response of
excitation or inhibition will these new
will this hidden units actually show and
based on the excitatory or inhibitory
input or mode of the hidden layer and
the weights of the input layer the
output layer is finally or the outputs
are finally determined and so that is
how we see that l1 or I 1 represents
gives to give rise to o2 and the hidden
layer the neural network or the group of
neurons which actually process it how
does it really function so this
particular model shows us gives us
several
benefit for example it it shows us what
are the neural codes which are there
which are which are which are
responsible for this kind of an output
and it distinguishes these neural codes
from mental representations so it
doesn't just tell you mental
representation of how event is
represented in memory but also what are
the brain states or what are the
neuronal states which are processing
this particular neuronal unit so that
brings us to the end of this session and
to do a quick recap in this session what
we did was we looked at the different
methods of studying cognition and we
looked at the heart of this study the
use of different methods that the the
basic point being that as we use
different methods we get seven whatever
the the Leupold from one method turns
out to be the benefit from another
method and so we got a more
comprehensive picture if one method
explains process a but cannot explain
process me maybe there is another method
which can explain process B and comes up
with another limitations and so looking
at the benefits and limitations on all
these methods gave us a more complete
picture of how cognitive Authority
processes develop and so within that we
looked at four different types of
methods or four different techniques of
studying cognition right from behavioral
techniques where we look at accuracy
response time judgments and protocol to
coming up with techniques which actually
go ahead and localized or pinpoint a
very brain area which is active when a
particular mental process is being
carried out and methods like eg PT MI
MRI or fMRI on optical imaging - looking
at Kaushal methods which actually
destruct a brain area which is believed
to be active when a particular event has
been taking place a vertical mental
event is being taking place - the
methods of modeling where a process is
designed a computer stimulation is
designed which mimics what the brain
does so instead of studying the brain
its
I'm a mimic or model of that is done and
studied through computer simulations to
find out what will happen if a
particular an input or a particular
group of brains brain areas which which
are known to respond in particular ways
if they take in an information how what
is the possible output that can come in
thank you
[Music]
you